le message qu'on veut faire passer c'est
clairement qu'il faut que ça change que
ça peut plus durer comme ça on a des
conditions de travail catastrophiques un
tant au niveau matériel humain et j'en
passe donc
là où il faut vraiment que ça change ce
qui va parce qu'il va pas c'est qu'on a
clairement très peu de considération et
de reconnaissance de la part de la
hiérarchie
de façon générale on sait nous faire
remarquer les erreurs qu'on peut
commettre ce qui est tout à fait normal
en revanche quand le travail est fait et
bien fait on ne dit pas ça manque
ça manque clairement
un totalité des collègues ça peut être
juste une juste une parole juste un
petit mot c'est quand même pas grand
chose mais ça c'est très rare c'est très
très rare
à force voilà du manque de considération
du manque de moyens de la surcharge de
travail pour certains ils finissent par
ne plus nous pu sortir la tête de l'eau
comme on dit et voilà certains pètent
les plantes clairement oui il ya
toujours des colas qui vont pas bien
après il ya ce qui qui arrive
parfaitement à la cache et aussi vous
fais partie des gens qui vont pas bien
on a clairement été laissé de côté trop
longtemps à tout niveau où on est censé
réprimandé le conducteur lambda au
quotidien qui roule dans un véhicule en
mauvais état pas si c'est le comble
c'est le comble quand on voit nous
l'état de nos véhicules
c'est pas c'est pas logique c'est pas
possible là car de police secours
qu on est actuellement obligé
d'utiliser pour assurer les
interventions
mais où on nous explique qu'il ne faut
pas utiliser la porte latérale
est-ce qu'elles risquent tout simplement
de tomber à léo couston insalubre
insalubres les photos parlent d'elles
mêmes
voilà cessé dans un état catastrophique
voilà au niveau de l'hygiène voilà notre
salle de pause les chaises de la salle
de pauvres à la dans les sanitaires les
voies trousses du public
alors ça ce sont ceux qui sont
accessibles au public
qui se trouve juste à côté nous de notre
salle de pause
voilà savoir que ce lavabo l endroit ou
non
on fait nos devait de celle ci on a
besoin de faire quoi c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué le conte c'est quelque
part en finit quand même par s'y
habituer
et c'est là que c'est vraiment
problématique quoi de travail il a il a
évolué de plus en plus compliquée par
rapport aux incivilités des gens qu'elle
nous avait à faire oui au filet au fil
du temps on s'aperçoit que qu'elles sont
plus en plus nombreuses à notre regard
plus en plus violente plus en plus
violente aussi mais ça se manifeste
commencé des insultes c'est quoi ça peut
aller de la simple parole al insulte aux
violences physiques est la hiérarchie
elle réagit te ment par rapport à ça
[Applaudissements]
la hiérarchie en fait on a clairement le
sentiment qu'elle est déconnecté de la
réalité
c'est nous qui sommes sur le terrain à
subir ces violences de façon récurrente
c'est pas la hiérarchie ça reste
difficile malgré tout on aime quand même
notre boulot voilà c'est ça qui fait qui
fait tenir c'est pas autre chose